what's going on guys this is Rob and we
continue now with part two of time runs
out now in the last video we spent a lot
of time focusing on Steve Rogers we
spent a lot of time talking about Steve
Rogers talking about what it is that he
was doing his pursuit of the Illuminati
as well as talking about sunspot forming
the multiversal Avengers based on the
members of the Avengers that had left
Steve Rogers after he began hunting the
Illuminati now what sunspot also did
here as he split the I guess what his
own Avengers team into two groups the
first group would travel into the
multiverse and try to find a way to stop
the collapse of the multiverse the other
group would stay on earth in order to
try to maintain law and order
since Steve Rogers basically wasn't
doing that since he was devoting all his
time and resources to tracking down the
Illuminati and so what we do here is we
basically pick up with the Illuminati
and what we find is that when multiple
members of The Avengers had left Steve
Rogers that one of the individuals who
had stayed was Susan storm then the idea
here was that Susan storm was avidly
against the actions of Reed Richards she
was staunchly against him basically
trying to evade Steve Rogers or at the
very least presumably destroying worlds
but what we learn is that this is
actually a ruse that in fact Susan storm
has been a spy for the Illuminati inside
the team of Steve Rogers ever since her
introduction now we don't exactly know
when this happened we just know that she
became part of that team at some point
in time and so what happens here is that
this basically gives us an understanding
of why it was the Illuminati were always
able to stay a step ahead of Steve
Rogers this was really kind of I guess
some tips that were given at the hands
of Susan storm in addition to the
combined intellect of the Illuminati and
so what we do as we learn this
information from Susan storm Reed
Richards is that we also see the Susan
storm gives a note to Reed Richards
which was written by Valyria Richards by
the daughter of Reed and Susan now we
haven't really talked about Valyria
Richards in depth and the reason for
that is because she doesn't really have
a whole lot of instances where she has
important parts and stories she has an
important parts periodically such as in
this story but for the most part she's
just a supporting character who's just
there so that we know what it is they're
doing in any
her story that happens to be going on
that involves a fantastic for now is
kind of a brief run over valaria
Richards is a sort of hybrid between
Reed Richards and Susan storm in the
sense that she can create force fields
like Susan storm can but she can't make
herself invisible Valyria Richards also
has an intellect that rivals both Doctor
Doom and Reed Richards and she's also
able to neutralize the powers of
Franklin Richards and so in terms of
what is she's capable of she's a
relatively interesting character here
but nonetheless the note that she gave
to Reed Richards basically says that
there's no way to stop the collapse of
the multiverse and that the only thing
they can really do at this point in time
is try to find a way to not lose that is
to say to try to make basically these
multiversal lifeboats these boats that
will allow them to survive the collapse
of the multiverse and then join whatever
this new multiverse is it comes into
existence after the collapse of the
current multiverse which as we know this
will be battleworld and so this is
basically Marvel telling us this is
presumably the road that Reed Richards
is going to attain going to take to
allow them to step into the battleworld
universe without actually dying at the
end of everything and so what happens
here with Reed Richards being confronted
with this information is he basically
realizes that the only way for them to
successfully bring an end or three at
the very least try to survive the
collapse of the multiverse is to
effectively in the fighting with Steve
Rogers and so what he does is he and the
Illuminati basically send out a signal
which Steve Rogers immediately
intercepts and then tracks eventually
taking him to the location of where the
Illuminati are at and so what happens is
Steve Rogers basically brings an entire
complement of shield forces along with
remaining Avengers at his disposal and
they immediately descend on New York and
try to attack the Illuminati but what
happens here is that while this conflict
leads to almost a total destruction of
New York we eventually see the Susan
storm basically abandons her role as
being a spy for for Steve Rogers and she
begins placing all the members of Steve
Rogers team and these sort of forcefield
cubes in the sense that they can't
escape and what this does is it gives
the Illuminati a chance to basically
begin talking to Steve Rogers to
basically tell Steve Rogers what is it
they're doing and what they've been
doing this entire time and so once
everybody
pretty much settled down Steve Rogers
again reminds the Illuminati that the
whole reason why he's hunting them is
because of the fact that they had been
destroying worlds but the Illuminati
argued that at this point in time while
they have destroyed a world previously
the only thing that really matters at
this point is one stopping the cabal of
namor the sub-mariner which again this
composed of Thanos a group that's
basically been raising different worlds
and actually has been destroying other
worlds but the other thing that they
need to worry about is trying to survive
the collapse of the multiverse and so
what they do is they devised a plan to
basically get rid of the Cabal what they
say is that when the next occur
incursion takes place that they're going
to have name of the sub-mariner travel
with the Cabal to whatever that planet
happens to be then what they're going to
do is a name of the sub-mariner is going
to abandon the Cabal on that planet and
then destroy that planet effectively
destroying the Cabal entirely but what
happens here is that when name of the
sub-mariner and his cabal travel travel
to this world that black panther and
Black Bolt travels to the world along
with name of the sub-mariner and what
they do is they basically knock
submariner down they knock him out and
they leave him on that planet they trap
in there and then they basically allow
the incursion to continue which pretty
much means as far as name of the
sub-mariner is concerned he is going to
die along with the Cabal but what's
really interesting here is that while
the incursion between this alternate
earth and the mainstream model earth is
taking place what we find is that a
third earth appears and this third earth
is actually the ultimate universe and so
what happens is in a last act of
desperation for survival
we find that name of the sub-mariner
Thanos and other members of the Cabal
jump to the ultimate universe and so
what we'll find later on is that we'll
pick up with them when they arrive in
this new reality with ultimate Reed
Richards and those characters and try to
figure out a way to again basically make
it back to their own reality or else
survive the end of the multiverse now
from here what we're going to do is
we're going to jump to the mostly
multiversal Avengers which are again out
in the multiverse composed of Hyperion
Odin sun night mask and star brand now
again if you're curious about night
masks and star brand I would highly
suggest that you check those videos out
there really a little too in-depth for
us to explain in this video but what we
find
is that Thor and the multiversal
Avengers had been traversing the
multiverse as we would expect him to you
and along the way to their current
location they'd come across an alternate
reality whereby a version of millinery
had existed that was designed
specifically for those who were unworthy
and so what happened was that that
alternate reality version of Thor was
defeated and Odin son took that hammer
for himself and that's why it is that he
currently has a hammer in this this
current runner in the current events of
time runs out but again where we had
previously believed that the black
crease which again are basically mystics
with unknown origins while we believe
that the black priests are basically
trying to speed up the destruction of
the multiverse by destroying other
worlds what we learn is that this isn't
necessarily the case what happens is
that as soon as the multiversal Avengers
arrive in what appears to be the home
base of the black priests they
immediately attack what happens is that
as the multiversal Avengers are finding
the black priests the group is joined by
Doctor Strange and what he tells us is
that the black priests have been trying
to save the multiverse that rather than
destroying worlds to try to speed up the
end of everything they've been
destroying the world as showing worlds
in the hopes that it would balance
everything out almost like a pot boiling
over and then turning down the heat
that's basically what the black priests
were trying to do here but ultimately
they've been unsuccessful up to this
point and so what Doctor Strange says is
that they should combine forces the
multiversal Avengers should combine with
the black priests and they should split
into two teams the first team should go
after ribbon a law and the second team
should go after the ivory kings now at
this point in the story we didn't know
who the ivory kings were but of course
we know right now that the ivory kings
are basically the beyonders which again
I have a video on that covers both the
Beyonder from the original Secret Wars
event as well as this group that
beyonders and what it is that they're
capable of with that being said we're
going go ahead and bring this video to
an end I hope it was a whole it was
clear as mud time runs out gets a little
hazy after a while but hopefully I
explained it in a way that you guys
understand and yeah so
and we'll catch you guys later peace no
kids
out in the
like ashes
by